to get an opportunity to present on my
work I spent the summer in Afghanistan
this past summer interviewing educators
teachers who spent 30 40 years of their
life teaching in time of conflict in
this presentation I will talk about I'll
focus on three points I will talk about
how I got introduced to oral history and
why I chose oral history as my methods
and and the second point is why I think
oral history is important and it could
play a significant role in preserving
the histories of societies that are
trying to emerge out of conflict and I
will focus on the example of Afghanistan
to try to explain that significance that
I see in the oral history and lastly
I'll show a few clips of my interviews
that I did over summer and we will have
a discussion about some specific
elements and some observations that I
have about the clips about about memory
and how and how you know certain
narratives are constructed in the memory
and how these individuals that I've
picked these clips purposefully because
they really tell about how they
construct these these these you know
memories so why did I choose oral
history as my message it's interesting
because usually when people decide to do
research they they decide on a field or
subject and then they you know choose a
method and then they go reach out to
subjects for me it was completely the
other way around
I knew my subjects way before I knew
battle history I will explain how this
happened I came to the u.s. seven years
ago as a freshman in high school on
scholarship
with the help of an organization called
seeds of peace and
I left the school that I left behind
that Afghanistan was an absolutely
horrible shape it was it was notorious
for for for the amount of violence that
happened at the school for the number of
times a week people got stabbed a hit or
the number of times that teachers were
wrestled down my students in the
classroom or or physically to the school
wasn't absolutely you know awful shape
there were no windows no no no furniture
no and it was the school the school that
I went to is little is in the middle of
a bazaar and it didn't have any walls
that didn't close it from from its
surroundings and what would happen in
the afternoons would be that shopkeepers
from from the local bazaar would make
their way to the school after they've
had a nice lunch and they'll find a
corner on campus just take their
afternoon dump it was just absolutely
open the campus is absolutely open with
no no sense of you know a school campus
because it didn't have any walls it
wasn't closed closed off so this is the
school that I left behind in 2003 when I
came to the US and I mean if I if I give
you the image without telling you that
it was a school you would think it's
it's you know it's an abandoned building
it's it's it's some sort of ruins the
only the only thing that Marx did as
school is because some some you know
transmission of knowledge happened
during the day because about you know
thirty to forty percent of teachers on a
lucky day would show up so this is 2003
I come to the u.s. in 2003 and I start
school here but I go back every year to
Afghanistan in subsequent years and
every time that I went back to
Afghanistan I was incredibly surprised
and impressed by by the amount of
progress that was made at the school
between 2003 and 2005 2006 the school
completely transformed from from from
the rules that it was into a very
vibrant very beautiful very green
you know campus where there was
discipline there was order there was
actually you know learning and teaching
happening and I got involved in the
school too late you know I did some
community service projects and and I got
a chance to closely observe what was
happening at the school and I was
curious to see why the progress or how
the progress was so rapid I mean there's
progress happening in general in the
country because there's a lot of money
flowing in and there's a lot of
international attention since 2001 but
the pace in which the progress was
happening at the school was you know
incredible to me
so I you know I looked closer and and
what I found was that most of the
progress that had happened was because
of the innovative leadership style that
the principal of the school had it was
most of pretty much everything that
happened was due to his style of
leadership and how he could use the
resources that he had which weren't much
at all to - you know - to build to
rebuild a school um we will she will see
a clip of the principal talking about
his experience in a few minutes but this
guy was absolutely incredible he this is
a school of 10,000 students 10,000
students a public school it has only a
couple buildings and it runs in four
shifts a day the stars at 6:30 say first
shift goes from 6:30 to 10 then the
second shift of students come in from
10:00 to 2:00 and then four shifts a day
and the last shift in 7:30 in the
evening this principal would come in
6:30 in the morning and be at school
till 7:30 around 10,000 students who
were you know who were notorious for
being roads and and and and you know
violence but the school was absolutely
known for how violent it was in Kabul
but this guy changed the school within
two or three years into one of the top
institutions in Kabul both in the sense
that it produced it graduated really
smart students and will train students
but also because it had
had a very conducive environment for
learning so ie I took a closer look at
him and I observed how he went about his
his leadership and and to show you the
the innovative style of his leadership I
would share an example of something that
he did that I think I've shared with you
described put together a disciplinary
system that was absolutely fascinating
to me in the traditional way a student
would be disciplined by you know getting
beaten in there in the palms of their
hands with a stick or even the soles of
their feet if they if they did something
wrong or if you're lucky you could get
away with just you know getting a quick
slap in your face because it's you get a
sensation where you get slapped but it
doesn't last that long but if you get
hit and be beaten with a stick it lasts
longer than when the the pain that you
feel from the slap so this is a
traditional method of how you know
discipline and punishment happen in
schools but this guy changed that what
he did was he put a penal system like a
fine system in place where if a student
did something wrong say if a student had
five absences and a month he wouldn't
get beaten five times in the palm of his
hand
but he would be fine to bring five
bushes and plant them into school or he
would be he would be he would be fine to
do to pump five hours of water and you
know water thus rejuvenated garden after
school or or or he would have to you
know shovel the dirt for five hours
because as I told you the school was
completely you know there was a ruins
there was nothing growing there before
so in the Dussehra bleeded preparation
for things to grow again so the student
that would be you know the punishment
would be to have the student out there
in the sun shoveling the dirt for five
hours or the risks there's that there's
a hierarchy of punishment the worst was
our main the traditional way of
fertilizing the land still is you know a
human manure so the worst was that the
student would get to bring some manure
to the campus to fertilize
no the the garden so this is it's it's
very innovative in a sense that and a
sense that he you served multiple
problems with this with this you know
this this style of punishment and
discipline in the short term he took
care of you know the greenery in the
garden because you have your resources
you know to to hire gardeners or the
people to do the work so your own
resources the student body you use it
and it was a long-term solution to if
you put the student to work into
creating the garden it's more likely
that he won't destroy it
he'll protect it so it's for me things
one of things I guess that he did were
absolutely fascinating um so having
observed these things I came back to
Colombia with a mission that uh that I
wanted to bring this guy to the US safer
for a month month long tour to give him
a chance to see you know high schools as
well as colleges because he has never
been abroad but if but if you see how
innovative he gets and how manipulate
how he manipulates the little resource
that he has I thought I thought a trip
abroad for him would would do two goods
first that he would get to see you know
other systems of education and how
people go that teaching and organizing
and leading schools and secondly because
I thought he had an incredible story to
share and and to to to people here and
to share with people here that uh that
that how how do people go about about
managing or leading the school in such
difficult times they have to get
creative so this was my mission I came
back to Colombia I was trying to get
this guy over here um I worked on over a
year it just financially just just
wasn't possible
I spoke to people you know apply for
grants and everything but it didn't work
out I needed about five thousand dollars
for it I didn't give up on spreading the
word about him but uh but I had to you
know give up the idea of bringing him
here
so I wrote about him too you know
certain papers and stuff like that it
was about that time that uh that I was
trying to look into other ways of
spreading the word about him that that I
had seen to the lecture but Mary
Marshall about oral history where you
give a presentation at the cusp and as
she talked about you know the power of
the methods and and and and how it's it
and I realize how it could be an
immediate solution to what I was trying
to do to spread his story to get a story
out but also a long-term solution to
make sure that his story is recorded and
his story remains to people who are
interested in in in the education and
the history of education but just to
people down the line who will be curious
about how people how these guys went
about leading the schools and there's
such difficult circumstances so when I
listen to a lecture by Mary Marshall I
realized that oral history could be
useful to me as a method and when I say
it when I say that my subjects found my
recent method this is what I mean that
that I had my subjects in mind first
before I decided on oral history so so
far I've talked about you know he about
oral history in the sense that it helped
fulfill my immediate needs of getting
this story at but what does this have to
do with with with the notion of archive
and and and and and and when I say that
oral history is important to
post-conflict societies how do those
things related about the same time that
I decided on oral history is my method I
ran across a I came across a article on
BBC about and the article confirmed some
fears and doubts that I had about about
history in Afghanistan first of all the
article vertical is about the history of
about history textbooks in the Afghan
curriculum like the current textbooks
that are used to teach students
in Afghanistan the first thing the
article focused was on was pretty
fascinating to me it showed how buys the
languages and how there is a lot of
political propaganda and in political
purpose behind the way the books are
written as an example to show you what I
mean by this the article give a quotes
from one of the history textbook
textbooks in Afghanistan on the issue of
Kashmir this is international history to
us so the history of Kashmir the idiom
the the language is described in is is
this it says the land grabbing and
greedy Prime Minister of India it would
not give up Kashmir to our Muslim and
brother friends Pakistan who are the
rightful owners of the land and I can
testify to to this language because I
use similar textbook this is the
language that you know the history
textbook is written in that that our
students get trained with this is the
first thing that the BBC article focused
on the second and the more important
point was that it had a quote from the
Minister of Education on on the writing
of local history the Minister of
Education said that it would take
Afghanistan another 30 to 40 years of
least before a factual history of the
violence that happened the past 40 years
could be written this is this is you
know the official staying the Ministry
of Education saying that it would take
at least three to four decades before a
faction before the time is right for
factual history to be written and why is
that I want to and explain this point a
little and and it will show the
importance of what I mean why I think
oral history can play a significant role
in conflict areas so why can't the
history of the past 30 40 years
Afghanistan not be written right away
well it's a history of absolute
devastation and brutality of civil war
30 years I mean at least 20 years of
that was brutality it's just blood
people are dying and those 20 years six
million people left the country this is
this a quarter of the population six
million people it's it's the number that
even the tragedies of Rwanda and Darfur
can can match and and all this happened
because there was a power vacuum left
when the Soviet Union withdrew from
Afghanistan and the communist regime
fell there's a power vacuum left and
political parties started fighting over
power civil war broke out and in this
civil war in several war lasted for
about 10 to 15 years thousands and
thousands of people died and six million
people left the country so if this is
the history of the past 30 years of
Afghanistan the history of suffering
because of civil war
now the history can be written because
those elements who caused the suffering
are still prominent in the society the
people who caused the bloodshed the
people who took you know took away a lot
of lives are still very prominent in
society when when when a society comes
out of conflict it doesn't when there's
relative peace it doesn't mean all as
well it doesn't mean you know there's
freedom to write whatever you want
however you want because those elements
who caused the suffering will be around
for another until they say that so the
history a factual history of Afghanistan
could not be written for this reason but
these people who fought over Fowler who
who you know who caused all the
suffering are still pretty much
comfortable in the country in one way or
another directly or indirectly they will
not let you know anyone who spends the
idea of a factual history you know get
to get to their goal they will they'll
get in the way so this is this is one of
the reasons why I think oral history is
important if and I now get to that is
and also if you have such turbulence
over 30 years where 6 million people
just leave the country I can give you an
image of what Kabul looked like during
these 10 years people just left behind
furnished houses because all they could
do was you know protect their family and
and leave the country with their family
they don't care about their belongings
Kabul was like a ghost town just painted
with blood all over for about 6 or 7
years if if you've got such turbulence
where people the only thing people care
about is their lives and trying to save
them their loved ones you can hold for
much of an archive to remain and to be
preserved and protected so for 30 years
all people cared about was their lives
about trying to give their family who
trying to get peace try to try to find a
safe shelter you can't you can't expect
an archive either either the archives
the government archives that we had got
caught in the crossfire and you know
got burned that way or or or got
systematically destroyed by political
parties who saw the archive as as you
know against what they were trying to do
so if you're if you're coming out of
such a history of thirty years where the
archive pretty much doesn't exist but
the history cannot be written for
another thirty years because the
elements who caused the suffering of the
lives and also the archive are still
prominent to society if you come out of
such such a such a situation the risk
you run is is is losing a lot of stories
losing a lot of historical knowledge
until the time is right for it to be
written down so now there's relative
peace but the history can not be written
for another thirty years this
transitional period the generation who
suffered during the Civil War
they will they will they will die they
will they will pass their time but their
history cannot be written for another
thirty years
so we it's a huge risk of losing all
those stories and if the history of
thirty years pretty much the history of
the suffering of a people we need to
make sure that those stories are
archived and recorded for when the time
is right for it to be incorporated into
history that's that's what I think oral
history can play an absolutely crucial
crucial role that it it it's a method
that could meet our immediate needs of
preserving these stories and preserving
these stories in a way that that the
power of oral history for me is the fact
that the individual who's telling the
story has complete control over it you
know if somebody else if you think of
the conventional sense of history it's
the author who spends the evidence
anyway he or she wants but in all
history it's the individual telling the
story as complete control of it
the only I mean the only the only the
closest thing that the role of the
interviewee comes to is is a role of a
collaborator you know of generating
questions to make sure you get a
complete story to try to get as much
detail as possible so if not only not
only is this oil has to be an asset
helpful in a sense that will be we'll be
recording these stories and and
preserving historical information but
but will also be honoring the suffering
of the people in the past 30 years by
giving them the agency over their
history you know by giving them the
opportunity to tell the story to tell
their history in their own voice rather
than having someone else write about
them especially if it's going to be
written about 30 years later there's
going to be very little accuracy to it
if the information is not preserved so
that's why I think oral history has can
play a very significant role in such
societies like Afghanistan that's
emerging out of conflict and with that
realization in mind I I went to home
this summer to try to try to carry a
little oral history projects of my own
by interviewing by going back to the
same school that that I went to before
coming here and by interviewing and
recording the stories of the people who
not only taught and they're incredibly
incredibly difficult circumstances which
which you know I was I was a witness to
I most of the teachers for I came here
when I was in ninth grade before that
the teachers would come to school but
there would be two or three months in a
row that they wouldn't get salaries but
they would still come to school and they
were so you know attend classes and try
to teach when when you've got bombs and
rockets flying over when when a lot of
when pretty much 90% of teachers outside
jobs of selling potatoes on the street
or you know or you know driving a taxi
around in their spare time because the
money they were making would eat was
either not being paid to them or what
their
making was not sufficient to keep to
keep their family families going so so I
went back to the same school and I
selected 443 teachers and the principal
that I wanted to sit down and interview
and record their their stories now the
challenge of of interviewing teachers is
twofold one I mean there's I got I got
trained over the summer I attended the
Summer Institute with maya marshall and
ron where there's a lot of you know
preparation work that goes in before
sitting down for the interview you you
look up background information on the
individual you read articles written
about them you know you you try to try
to learn as much as possible before you
sit down so you have good questions you
have good knowledge of the person so you
could you know generate as much detail
as possible but it's difficult with the
teachers because there's nothing written
about them how are we going to do that
background research if you know if
they're just ordinary citizens teachers
that was my first challenge and so I
basically spend the first month
just having you know a cup of tea with
them plain just having a casual
conversations try to get some background
detail nothing official but some
background detail and a sense of their
life before I could sit down with them
and you know ask him specific questions
so that was the first challenge the
second challenge is that the teachers
and I used to talking about themselves
if you sit down at a politician or a
leader they could go on for five hours
talking about themselves they've done
that all their lives but if but if you
sit down at a teacher they don't really
have much to say they don't they don't
think of their stories as significant
especially especially in in in the
country like Afghanistan where ordinary
citizen has very little power very
little influence on what happens in the
country so this was my second challenge
how am I going to give these teachers to
talk to share their stories
and and it was quite a difficult
challenge that that now that I listened
to my first hours of interviews it's
like I would throw a question I would
give like a two-word answer there would
be a silence that I'd have to ask
another question and and for two of the
interviews this is what happened that I
had a difficult climb the first hour
trying to get the person to talk about
himself how it pause the interview and
and and and all over again
I'll give him the same explanation that
I tried before the interview that there
are there are people who really
interested in your story that not only
they want to they want to learn about
how you lived your life how you adapt to
these different conditions not only they
want to learn about it now but this is
an opportunity for you for your story to
be included in the future history that's
going to be written so I would repeat
out given this speech again that I had -
that I've prepared as part of my
preparatory month that I spent
researching and and then I would restart
the interview and start asking questions
again and and as they got more
comfortable and as they got you know
talking the answers would get longer and
longer and much more detailed much more
interesting so this was this was with
two of the teachers that I had this
problem yet or two teachers none of them
was a teacher one of them as it was a
principal the teacher it was a history
teacher and I had taken a class with him
when I was a student at the school and I
really liked his method of teaching
because what he would do is he would he
would give us he would teach us history
as if it was a story in very very simple
language he would just sit at the edge
of the table he would blow up his
sleeves
they'd just start talking as if as if it
was a it was a it was an anecdote it was
a it was a story and and and and he
would he would catch our attention that
way and most of people didn't have
textbooks to read about it and they
couldn't there are no labrys to do
research on people so the classroom that
one hour that you had with the teacher
per week was pretty much your only
chance to learn history and if you don't
have a good teacher who can capture your
attention
then that opportunity is lost as well
she was he was amazing at what he did he
would just set up dinner table he would
lecture for like 30 minutes he'd tell us
a story and then we will have two
students stand up and repeat the story
yes we would call you call the story
they would have two people repeat the
story the next day they would come in he
would you know ask two or three people
to to see if we remembered the previous
day's lesson and his his self punishment
was really interesting to that that he
would he would have three people stand
in front of the classroom usually one or
two people could you know manage an
answer and get away with it and and he
would have that person who managed the
answer to punish the other two and
there's literally it was actually start
a punishment he would have you would
have the student would answered for two
or three strings of hair from a from the
temple area of the students who couldn't
answer and tell so we the rest of
students are just sitting there and
watching this happen and oh I read if
our classmates had beards and there were
like older students because because
there was a discrepancy in and you know
there in their education system because
they're going to go to school five or
six years so you see this 20 year old
guys standing upon the classroom
including me answer the question and
then you have somebody like me you know
30 and 12 years old
tiny trying to plant a couple strings of
hair and try a precious guy and you see
you know tears flowing in the eyes of
this 20 year over the beard and
everybody in the classroom is just
watching I mean maybe maybe that's not
this the part of his teaching method
that I had a focus in math but but the
way he told the way he captured
attention was fascinating and his style
of dressing was really interesting for
me too that in 2002 when schools
restarted teachers were required to wear
western dust like a suit or a shirt with
you know jeans or you know a dress pants
but this guy you will see a picture from
there's a huge beard he's like 60 65 and
he was used to wearing a turban in the
traditional clothes so when he was when
he is required to wear everything's
this Western suit for the first couple
of weeks who resisted it you just come
in and his turban and his traditional
clothes and you just lecture you didn't
really care about anyone at all and then
you know the administrators got more
rigid and asked him to do start wearing
you know your suits so he posed some old
suit that he had from 30 years back what
he would do is if you would wear the
suit on top of traditional clothes we
get the traditional clothes you have
long shirts right so you would not feel
the need to to take off his shirt and
wear you know like these short dress
shirts what do you do with you tuck in
his long shirt into his western pants
then who where you know the jackets on
top of it and he would not take his
turban off so you got this guy wearing a
Western suit with a traditional turban
and a huge beard but that didn't take
the didn't take away at all from you
know from how we learned from him and
and his style of teaching so he was one
of the people that I pointed out that I
wanted to go to and has his story
because I knew he had gone through a lot
through the 65 years old and I wanted to
get his story he will be the first flip
that we will see the second person was
the principal I got really close to him
because I went back and I did a couple
community service projects and and and
and I really I mean I can't say I used
the fact that I got so close to him but
but it built a comfort between us but I
didn't have the theater 3 teachers but I
had to I have to establish that comfort
with the you know 3 whereas I had I had
it with the principal and I guess being
the principal it's kind of a political
role as well so he was used to talking
about himself and I had a much easier
time adding him speak I think I
interviewed him for 5 to 6 hours and
during those 6 hours I don't think I
asked more than 12 or 13 questions
whereas whereas whereas with the other
teachers for two-hour interview probably
asked like 4050 questions it just is
shows you know how comfortable certain
people are comfortable in the sense of
you know their natural skills but also
because of the role that they have in
society and how that role shapes how
comfortable they are in talking about
themselves I'll play the first clip the
first clip is the history teacher 1972
is when pretty much communism
establishes in Afghanistan and the
Communists you know start their
government and he's talking about that
period that transition period were the
Republic Falls and we have a communist
government taking over so we'll we'll
see what he has to say about that
transitional period and then have a big
discussion with that
he says
from collection
a detective or shooting
rebellion has over hope you took Minami
sridham tariff there - absorbed by the
Nahuatl nickel aluminum video monochrome
and innovation kadai generation episode
auto body to science in Genova German
sharp Amish game body delivers Omega are
considered a yoga teacher
come on mega rayquaza personal papers oh
my god bless me macho macho much given
eternal devotion comedy doorman at the
corners and
now that I call me home I see the German
phonetic it was the height of the
Ottoman domination the Serbs awesome
another remove but I think I'm not just
innovation
I really good that's hopeless II don't
see you geriatric rate over that might
happen
oh my god so he could be so hard on all
my issues
when
but you have you know you can show
whatever house separately
Jessica did not - I before machinery
is such a socially
I think that was you follow me push the
video technicality Commerce director
action
secondly economist the holy essential
point which is yes when I confess the
fish
Connecticut's Award nomination as much
as an observer when we are wrong with
our additional images exactly to our
silk organza do that
this year - include the cabbage
there are few things about this specific
fact the question that I translated the
beginning was pretty much the question I
asked him I didn't tell him what way to
tell me a story or to give me any
information about Kadir I didn't know
that he was going to tell me about
career but it's it's amazing how he
structured the story for us but that he
started with a very you know general
image of what was happening in the
society right at the transitions in
Republic 2 to a revolutionary communist
period and then he got specific to
individual and then he went back few
years tell a story about how they had
come to Kabul to buy fabric and that she
had a little joke and he did all this
without me really asking anything the
only question that I had was a very
general question of just tell me about
what things were like when the
revolution happened where were you and
it's it's amazing how he made these
connections for one reason because he's
used to telling stories of sitting at
the edge of the table and just and just
just used to making connections between
historical events and saying it in a way
that makes sense to us as the listener
that skill is very you know apparent
here um but but the detail that he gives
is absolutely incredible - I mean the
gesture of his hand when he talks about
the husband but the wife licking the
blood just few words and that one
gesture is incredible I mean it raises a
question about video that we talked
about they were talked about in the
summer Institute's but oral history has
traditionally been done audio and just
transcript but here we see the power of
the image could have as well but it's
true that if it's a good quality audio
you know the grain of the voice comes
through and you kind of get a sense of
the emotion but you don't did that
gesture you don't you don't get the
emotions on the young individuals face
and
it's to me all those things put together
with the way that he structures his
memory he's absolutely incredible um I
thought I would open it up if anyone has
in you know comments about this clip
before I move on to show you the second
and last clip so if anyone has I thought
his eyes also his eyes were so sad
and so
this is the principal public
um he's talking about the year 1992 in
early 90s when so the previous clip was
about the transition from Republic to
the communist regime and 12 about 20
years have passed between the time that
the guy was talking he's talking about
well this is early nineties the
communist regime has just following the
Soviets of the throne from Afghanistan
this is when the Civil War happens
there's a huge vacuum of power Tom those
people were kicked out the Communists
start and infighting fighting each other
over power and as I said earlier Kabul
absolutely turns into a ghost town in an
image bloody bloody City so he's talking
about how that period affected this food
halo is going on in this one
my modules and perhaps they might have
some active on the moment they the
assimilative a castle with emoji the
back table
why
as my daughter occasions like that often
a song problem
I wasn't about that we said no no boy
that way that we can be victims it's
also people - be home - ostrich farm
ownership maximum piracy as much passing
that is material for his moji
don't be shy at all yours in the unique
art at all true to understand Johnson
did another party to enjoy Oh Tom you
say well to the values you know the
second one is our attorney
she cursory information tonight
simple switch to the bishop
sorry sukashi you know chaotic for the
market in the operating system it is not
a Japanese technique people to mother
the patio that is come over I think
there are more mata ashita which is
infinity and Odyssey is your opportunity
this religion you keep it down that
could be CK they said open holiday time
clearly rest like people down is a visit
theme that keeps coming up not only did
the students wrestle teachers down
principals administrators were using it
as a method to and I think an mi
probably recognizes the the dialect that
he speaks and and he's not he's not
talking he has a very cool very you know
street slang that he's talking about
that he's talking in and and that that
that's really that really represents his
his tire of leadership and management to
that but he doesn't he doesn't go
management books or he doesn't he just
he just tries to shape his style to the
needs of the students and the kind of
students that he's leading
and it's this an interesting story for
me too because for a couple years I went
to the same school where half of the
school was literally divided just the
way he's talking about that families
were living in the classrooms you had
they had I said the classrooms didn't
have windows and you know doors they had
cloths and curtains covering but rude to
try to you know keep away the cold in
the winter and they actually had ovens
and they had heaters like wood heaters
and wood stoves inside inside the
classrooms that's how they warmed up
basically the school was turned into you
know like a refugee camp and he does an
amazing job just describing he he goes
on and lists and lists and lists all
these things you know like you you feel
like he's about to stop and then another
thing comes to him he goes oh when they
brought in huge rocks to chop woods and
the nice talks and they all they started
fires in the classrooms clearly
he has a lot in his heart that he wants
to do honestly just unload and share
with people this is pretty much what I
had the two clips that I showed I
haven't really gotten to edit the other
the other interviews that I've done yet
this is pretty much it's a little
difficult doing subtitles and
translating the way they speak to try to
keep you know the the nature of how
they're saying it they're the
originality of it but also make it make
it you know so make sense in English
Alyssa bill is helping me a lot try to
try to capture that because sometimes I
I would literally translate words word
and then they wouldn't make sense in
English but I still really wanted to
keep that original nature of it because
the way they speak the way they share
the stories it's as important as the
stories themself so if you guys have any
comments any